talk about your relationship with ellie  chapa because i remember  like the first couple times they hung  out with him  he said that like he really like you  guys are really locked in and like you  kind of mm-hmm  like like back in the day [ __ ]  like when me me and choppa uh we didn't  grow up knowing each other but like me  coming up i used to do these little  instagrams  so i made the instagram live so i used  to go live  and i used to check [ __ ] on  there so i didn't [ __ ] around and  looked at chopper now me and choppa had  a little roast station me and that road  session ever since then i just knew him  so every time i went on my life i added  chopper  well before he even started rapping so  he sent me some [ __ ] he was like he had  a song and [ __ ]  he sent me the song and then he dropped  the video and went from going crazy like  yeah  he did it yeah he's doing his thing for  sure